les chéis vous avez vu ce chauffeur
français qui réalise la plus longue
course uber un trajet en question un
départ d'Anglette une commune située
dans les Pyrénées d'Atlantique et une
arrivée à Dortmund en Allemagne zoir un
chauffeur de 41 ans donc parcouru pas
moins de 1300 km en 14 he pour la somme
de 200 € C un couple un couple qui avait
peur de prendre l'avion regardez j'ai
été contacté par l'application une
course entre anglette et Dortmund en
Allemagne au début j'ai cru que c'était
une blague je me su rendu et c'était la
réalité un couple m'attendait les prix
étaient exorbitants ayant peur de
l'avion surtout la dame euh bah ils ont
préféré prendre un uber voilà moi je
pense que j'ai effectué 1342 km moi j'ai
j'ai touché brut 1800 € j'ai dû avoir
500 600 € de frais au niveau péage au
niveau carburant
donc net en faisant les calcul j'ai plus
1000 € largement net dans ma
poche
on peut se poser la question si c'est
rentable vraiment non parce qu'après il
va devoir rentrer il va rentrer tout
seul à vide ça va ça y il l' AA dit il a
dit a tout comis il reste 1000 € dans
sa ouais mais je suis pas sûr que ça
soit rentable pour le coup quand même de
faire des courend il vient de dire il
vient de dire qu'il a gagné 1800 balles
ouais mais non moi je pense je rig il
fait pas 1000 € la journée à 100 € près
il battait le record français qui était
de 2200 € qui était Gard de l'Est
munique ah ou et il a respecté toutes
pause Paris il s'est arrêté trois fois
comme prévu même si le le couple qui
dormait dans la voiture était pressé
c'est bien franchement ouais la course
moi qui m'est revenu le plus cher
j'étais pas dedans en plus ça m'a coûté
plus de 500 € comme ça j'avais
rendez-vous avec une fille que je ne
connaissais pas jeis dit de venir chez
moi j'habitais à l'époque vers d'fer
rocherau elle connaissait pas bien Paris
Paris dans Paris voilà et elle
connaissait pas bien Paris et elle me
dit mais c'est où et cetera je d'fer
rocherau là où il y a le lion le lion
parce qu'il y a une lion au milieu de la
place en fer encher et le seul truc
qu'elle a retenir qu'elle a retenu c'est
le lion elle est rentrée dans
l'ubert elle a dit Lyon au bout de 2
heur je vois toujours pas je pensis
qu'elle se prépar
j'appelle retour 460
€ je
mauvaise
m qu' F dans le monde de la livraison
nous c'est qu'à chaque fois on dit un
gars va livrer Gard de Lon et il va Gard
de Lyon mais il va pas dans le 12
arrendiss de Paris il va directement lui
à la gare de Lyon et il appelle il dit
j'ai plus d'essence mais comment tu tuas
pas mis le plein ce matin si j'ai mis le
plein ce matin mais j'ai bouffé tout le
plein tu peux pas bouffer tout le plein
dans la gare de lion et il est parti à
Gard de Lyon c'est pour ça que je ne
crois pas à ton histoire je crois pas tu
penses que je
men m tout le monde cette c'est très
grave tu dis ah tu penses que c'est
c'est fa c'est Pipo ça c'est comme la
légende urbaine va gare de Lyon le mec
il par la gare de Lyon il y a jamais
personne qui est parti à G mais moi je
suis pas dans ton
monde vra vieana tu dis jeis lon vous me
croyez pastenant c'est impossible non
par que tu es viment un connard toi plus
cassé un couple il dit que je m mais
vous arrêtez les me tu dis pas au uber
où tu vas en
plus on est en
2023 pas
uber j'ai pas
jus j'ai2
ansus
bizarre elle a trouvé où le taxi
clandestin pas nous auji je lui ai
envoyé tuas envoyé un taxi clandestin
mais je connais excuse-moi tu as
peut-être personne dans ton répertoire
moi je connais des gens qui font taxi
comme ça pour dépanner pour faire un peu
de tune le soir en plus que je
pr tu l' appelé tu Luas dit qu'il allait
devais aller à Lyon ouais non c'est elle
qui a dit er à Lyon je lui ai envoyé le
truc et quand ser est-ce que tu peux
nous raconter
l'histoire lui envoyé j'avais dans mes
contacts un chauffeur voilà que je
connaais détail parce queou voilà
j'avais dans un chauffur tu l'as
toujours sur le chauffeur si tu l'avais
tu l'as t changé de téléphone CIN fois
fois
faire voilà et je lui ai envoyé je lui
dis quand tu seras dedans tu lui tu lui
donneras l'adresse à la fille je lui dis
je te l'ai envoyé je te dis quand il est
en bas et quand tu seras dedans tu lui
dis elle me dit tu habites où je lui dis
j'habite à d'fer rocher pratiquement sur
la place il était à 20 m du cinéma
comment il s'appelle je sais plus et je
lui dis quand tu seras arrivé à dansfer
mais c'est où dansferocher ça faisait 3
mois qu'elle était à Paris je lui dis
dans ferocher là où il y a le liyon la
est rentr lu et
elle tu aurais pu faire aussi le lion et
en fait s'est retrouvé dans un zo oui
sauf que ça ça serait mentir alors que
moi c'est vrai et quand je l'ai appelé 2
he elle était elle m'a dit dis-moi ce
que tu vois mais je suis sur l'autoroute
qu sur l'autoroute pas l'autoroute pour
aller elle m'a dit mais je vais écrire
au
ser interrogatoire j'ai une question
question précise le chauffeur clandestin
vous le connaissez ouais donc sans
rechigner vous appelez un chauffeur
clandestin il envoie quelqu'un à Lyon
alors qu'il sait que vous habitez
dans SAV pas où j'étais chauur sa pas où
j'étais le chauffur je lu ai dit d'aller
récupérer quelqu'un à Saint-Germain
dragon ai du dragon de la gueule de qui
vous
foutez Jean-Michel j'ai une question un
petit peu à vous poser vous aviez
rendez-vous à quelle heure avec cette
jeune fille vers 21h 21h30 à quelle
heure elle est à comment àelle heure
elle est j'ai appelé moi il était vers
23h30 il est mort donc elle a mis 2h3
pour faire 150 km ah oui c'est ça ouais
depuis saintgmain oui c'est peu près le
temps une autre question un peu et après
elle est revenu elle est reven à quelle
heure chez vous elle je l'ai pas laissé
au ser oui merci elle est revenue vers
quelle heure elle est revenue vers
quelle heure bah tu rajoutes de mais
c'est délire ce
truc la
tête alors ce quine c'est tu as payé
combien la course Paris au ser je crois
que c'était 460 € je crois et tu trouves
que c'est normal comme tuares c'est pas
louche pourquoi tu travailles chez uber
toi mais je suis d'accord avec elle
c'est pas assez ça va pas il il est
clandestin il a pas il
pasargent ça va pas de nuit ça va pas
procureur 5 clandestin 6 rint-germain en
lait 6 rue du Dragon pas Saint-Germain
en lait Saint-Germain dans le 6e tu as
dit Saint-Germain en lait tu as dit
Saint-Germain en la r du dragon
Saint-Germain des prê vous ça existe pas
dans l'Ouest Saint-Germain dans l'Ouest
il y a pas ça donc déjà ex par pas de
l'Ouest Saint-Germain des prê
Saint-Germain 6
arondiss
tris chff con même pas les adresses il
s'en sort pas mal il s'en sort pas mal
vous êtes toujours en contact avec la
jeune fille non mais je peux mais si
vous voulez je peux vous rapporter
toutes les preuves mardi prochain est-ce
que vous avez son numéro là non je je me
souviens mê plus de son prénom très
honnêtement c'était il y a 4 5 ans comme
par hasard comme par hasard moi je le
crois c'est pas mieux que tu nous dises
que c'est un
mythér vous
êtesètement
hisire de
mer je vais rechercher j'ai encore mes
vieux téléphone je vais faire des
recherches pour retrouver les textes je
envoyé je apporter le maximum de choses
justif i 460 € chez toiess en liquide
tuas payé liquide
est non mais vous savez qu'il y a des
appareils des distributeurs on
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
pe elle est arrivée vers 2h du matin je
retrouve le ticket du distributeur a
ouais c'était quelle soir de la semaine
ouais c'était un jeudi je crois mais
j'en sais rien mal le jeudi en Paris ça
circule mal le jeudi entre Paris et auoc
par Bison
F attends attends et donc tu es descendu
à quelle heure de chez toi pour prendre
l'oseille les 460 balles non mais c'est
une plaisanterie non non mais j'is une
camé caché
arrête j'ai su qu'elle allit arrivé je
suis descendu une demi-heure avant mais
en pensant qu'elle all arrivé vers vers
22h et après donc tu avais pas tuavis
pas retiré 460 balles au départ bah oui
non
mais
ah parce que vous vous retirez à chaque
fois pile vous allez acheter une
baguette vous retirez 2 € 1 frère entre
entre Saint-Germain des prês comme tu as
dit dans Paris et dans fer tu en a pour
50 balles sauf que je vais pas
distributeur quand j'y vais j'en profite
pour prendre un peu de liquidité
tu as pris 500 € au de 50 c'est beaucoup
ça c'est beaucoup j'en met c'est un
problèmeah oui oui c'est un
problème là je l' crié làus ça c'est
c'est
fini person car elle pas plafonnée
comment ta carte elle était pas
plafonnée non plaonnée pas de carte je
non mais j'ai pas une carte d'étudiant
j'ai 62 ans je te rappelle ça fait 40
ans que je
travailleage c'est dél tuussi de
retraite
a donc tu es descendu à 22h pensant
qu'elle arrivé retiré 500 € al saétait
50 balles je c'était 4 ans 5 ans vous
êes genti donc je me rends compte que là
come les gens sont accusés de choses qui
sont pass il y a longtemps ça compliqué
de se justifier parce que là je gè j'ai
peut-être retiré 100 balles comme ça et
sachant qu'elle éocr je suis redescendu
retiré plus d'argent ça vous va là bah
ça fait de
version on avance en marchant j'y
réfléchis les Svir tu vas dire c'est ce
que tu vas dire g réagissent je demande
au gens est-ce qu'il croient à
l'anecdote de Jean-Michel moi j'ai
question très précise Jean c'était quel
jour exactement
je veux le jour la date et là savoir s'
pleuvait si nigeait exactement je
demande exactement quelle était la météo
comme ça j'irit vérifier ouais oh là là
où il faisait nuit
déjà mais c'était quelle saison est-ce
qu'il faisait encore jou tu veux le jour
et tout c'était en au printemps en avril
mai et il pleuvait pas vérifie il y a
des nappes de brouillard à il y a des
nappes de brouillard à haoser est-ce
qu'il y avait du brouillard à haoser est
vous l'a dit le taxi il y avait des
éoliennes il y avait des éoliennes les
éolienes à cette époque là il y a
combien de temps il y a 4 ans ça je vais
vérifier plî on va voir on va voir gu
excuse-moi le jeudi à 21h 22h tu étais
pas sur le plateau il y a 4 ans hein le
jeudi
soir bah non à 22h on est plus sur
PL la quand as app pendant la pub'est-ce
qu'on
faituber est-ce que je sign que je je
fais pas tous les jours l'émission Les
jeud
j indiscutable indiscutable je peux
apper pendant la pu pour alors je vais
te laisser une dernière g Yve est-ce que
tu crois à l'histoire de Jean-Michel oui
bien sûr c'est vrai merci aristocrate
vou c'était moi le chauffeur
[Rires]
ah Jean-Michel on va voir ce qu'en pense
le public sur cette anecdote est-ce que
vous croyez à l'anecdote de Jean-M non
5 Jean-Michel pas normal de pas croire
allez Jean-Michel bah c'est normal j'ai
j'ai si gugus contre moi c'est normal
qu's y croi pas c'est pas normal de pas
cro allez je vais te laisser une
dernière chance une dernière chance de
quoi de dire la vérité et oui est-ce que
dis la vérité est-ce que tu as est-ce
que tu as menti ou pas pour la vanne
allez allez si c'était pour la vanne je
trouve ça très fort qu'est-ce que je
gagne si je dis la vérité à faire un
bonbot bah déjà mon estime
ouais pas mal c'est beaucoup et non je
veux la vérité est-ce que c'est vrai il
y a
pas alors c'est faux
mais
[Applaudissements]
fa c'est
faux mais ça a failli arriver ça a
failli
AR c'est fa c'est le chauffeur m'a dit
après qu'elle lui avait dit Lyon il
avait failli à Lyon et lui de lui-même
il a réagi cé pas c'est encore fa ver av
avait cré ça oua ah ouais il mérite une
récompense
franchement un cadeau maise j'aime pas
mentir en plus mais là j'aimais bien
cette histoire c'est pour
ça je fait cramer
bêt
[Applaudissements]
mais ici tu peux pas ici je t'explique
ici frère il y a que des loups ici
malade ou quoi dans tes soirées et tous
les Myth tous les Myth il ont icière il
a pas un truc qui frère tu es fou quoi
tu vois pas que tu as des loups ici SCON
on est tous tous mis sur tes côtes c'est
pas grave j'aimais bien j'ai fini
presque par croire pas une autre
anecdote que tu peux nous
raconter une vraie une vraie non
non faire une émission comme ça avec des
interrogatoires c'est pas mal bah
produit là
produit c'est pas mal oui des trucs vra
ou faux c'est fa des
trucs aès question questions ou on sera
très fort làdus ah mais je peux te dire
nous la vérité frères ici c'est c'est un
truc de fou entre Verdez ma Raymon frè
les trois tu les mets là déjà tu es mort
tuas qu'une envie tu dis allez vas-y
j'ai rien fait maisasy c'est bon
incarcérez-moi quel est le dernier
monsong que vous avez vous ayez fait
vous le dernier quoi le
mensonge
Raymon tu veux pas la dernière vérité un
seul un seul tu veux pas la dernière
vérité
[Applaudissements]
c'est
extraordinaire tiens pa c'est quoi le
dernier mytho que tu es fait mon âge B
ouais tu as dit que tu avais quel âge 19
20 pourquoi tu as dit ça j'aime pas mon
âge je suis vieille tu as 24 h mais là
j'ai la vérité j'ai j'ai guéri tu as
guéri j'ai gu j'ai guéri
sympa 24 c'est jeune is c'est jeune
j'aime pas tellement jeune